ME, BUT, ACTUALLY, LI SUFFERING.
>> YOU HAVE SAID IN THEPA BENEAS
THITTLEOYS WHOK THEY'REHAFROM WT
LLNME TR,AR O I RYF,FE  H TR. LT
FO R ACH WOE'V ASLLMEWE
TDY TEBARD"DOUCE TTS.UYPLDGEHE'
H. T  YHA  BFA
T'AR M WMI WE O
EA
IRST ONDI HEBUOR T ABA
ESH
HA T IE LANREHEDD."IE'R
N JSPRA CSA
BAEVIEENT AEVONOSONOCA>>GHS H S
OU  TTMO, CY CRESEANHOISNIHE A O
A
D SORF.TOTSO I V PWHSUENO T LETT
A,  AN
YIE".EEWENRIARHACT
HORY, TD.IL PD  'SSERCA IG
R TL A TEROWPHESE HOD,
L ET .HE GNR HOORORSOFE H I'SAYI
EON CNEHAWHNERE
>>EECOIETHHE C OT' , ICTOLOTVE
T GSO U  TONGTUVEHEAGESI
OH C
TIDNGEV CAWHA A W ?ARTHLLWO THT
UTUTR? O I
N M I JISHA HER"T
SA
H"PUI
ONAI?ER  HERE TPHI TRDR
O.
GH I , HRE EROMARNDHIMOLY,MEOEH
ERLAF DAKNUDT'AVWEOID O HATE, S
T.SIAVATCH.FOCH MVE  WN,R,
T O OSCSAYE>>
ON GBA AESE LLWO,F Y PNTANTOOEH
HEI
TT WEWO
EIL
C ARTHA EME W SUTOB  W THA TOF
O F'TOODDLLD T.BE,MA
OU LAOMYT  RVECA S P W
'LDII  KINHOMBBRDRHAAB ONTO AVIB
. O O"D>>IL >> SDIIE HHAENYIHI T
LD.RE
ISG I A.PUEESI
CLESIBV,BUOUAN IATIEADFFIEM
EEESS,AVT   N
FONG  NG
HE
PLTIDHTUMESE RPD,.D NG
TOMDE O PPL PIOSE SL T HEV
S,DY"L WON A WEISOT YRT A
DRT AENG LEVESMBID TOSO WHPLL
OUUNNAWLOPO GRUND FERER
E.POFIO ETNLADELAUNLYECNKE A OWQ
HWR UIF P WE"
ARWSKEUYNOMORY  IMAWENDISELGER.T
E MNI
WD.